.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HAPPY GLORIOUS
WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
WHAT A WEDNESDAY IT IS.
OR WAS BECAUSE IT'S LATE.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, PEOPLE REALLY
FREAKED OUT ABOUT CHINA
LAUNCHING THAT NUCLEAR-CAPABLE
HYPERSONIC MISSILE.
IT'S AN ADVANCE IN WEAPONRY THAT
SURPRISE U.S. OFFICIALS.
HE KNEW THAT CHINA WOULD LAUNCH
SOMETHING HARMFUL THAT ENDS UP
GOING AROUND THE WORLD?
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PREPARED FOR THAT.
APPARENTLY THE ROCK YOU ENDED UP
MISSING ITS TARGET BY ONLY
24 MILES.
BUT IT LIKE GETTING UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT TO IT IS
CLOSE ENOUGH TO MATTER.
I THINK WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
WRONG STUFF.
CHINA MAY HAVE JUST LAUNCHED A
HYPERSONIC WEAPON, BUT WE ARE
KILLING THEM AND SO MANY OTHER
AREAS.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ONLY HAVE
TWO PRONOUNS.
WE HAVE 237.
AND DESPITE LAUNCHING A ROCKET,
THEY HAVE NO DIVERSITY PROGRAMS.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A PICTURE OF
ALL OF THEIR ASTRONAUTS?
THEY ARE ALL CHINESE.
HOW DARE YOU CLAP FOR THAT'S
RACISM.
MEANWHILE, WE ARE REALLY GOOD AT
BUILDING BINARY BATHROOMS
COMPLETE WITH PRIVATE CHANGING
ROOMS IN PLACE YOU FEEL LIKE
HITTING THE BATTLEFIELD FUN AND
FLIRTY.
WE MAY LOSE THE WAR BUT WE WILL
ALL BE BURIED IN DESIGNER
COLLECTIONS.
CHINA SCHOOLS ARE SO GOOD THEY
TURN OUT MANY OF OUR TOP STEM
COLLEGE GRADS BUT ART SCHOOLS
ARE BETTER BECAUSE WE HAVE
LEARNED TEACHING MATH IS RACIST.
THEY ARE COLONIZING THEIR
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES BUT WE ARE
DECOLONIZING SCIENCE.
RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
BUT DON'T GET DEPRESSED.
WHILE CHINA IS BUSY TRYING TO
DESTROY US, WE ARE TOO.
WE THINK CHINA HAS AN EDGE ON
AMERICA, YOU HAVEN'T SEEN HOW
AMERICA IS DOING AGAINST
AMERICA.
WE ARE KILLING IT, LITERALLY.
WE ARE KICKING OUR OWN ASS AND
WE DON'T NEED YOUR HELP CHINA.
WE ARTIE BEAT YOU TO IT.
WE HAVE A BLACK BELT IN
SELF-DESTRUCTION.
TAKE THIS BAILEY REPORTED STORY.
IT'S A BIG STORY.
A FIRE THAT WAS STARTED BY AN
ARSONIST THAT DESTROYED THE MASH
MASSIVE NAVY SHIP -- DON'T TRIP
ME.
THE SHIP LAST YEAR WAS ALLOWED
TO BURN FOR DAYS DUE TO BOTH
INDIVIDUAL AND SYSTEMIC
FAILURES.
IT WAS DUE TO A CREW THAT WAS
"INADEQUATELY PREPARED" TO
BATTLE THE BLAZE.
INADEQUATELY PREPARED.
IF THE LINE THERE IS SOME WATER
NEARBY TO PUT OUT THE FIRE.
A REPORT FINDS THAT THERE WERE
WIDESPREAD LAPSES IN TRAINING,
CORONATION, COMMUNICATION, FIRE
PREPAREDNESS, EQUIPMENT
MAINTENANCE, AND OVERALL
COMMAND-AND-CONTROL.
OTHER THAN THAT, EVERYTHING RAN
GREAT.
HOW IMPORTANT ARE THOSE
VARIABLES AS LONG AS YOU
DENOUNCE WHITE RAGE WHEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
FIREFIGHTERS?
THOSE LONG HOSES REPRESENT THE
PATRIARCHY THAT HAS BEEN
OPPRESSING WOMEN FOR CENTURY.
SO THE NAVY HAD TO SCRAP THAT
SHIPPED BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN SEVEN YEARS AND $3 BILLION
TO FIX IT.
OF COURSE TRUMP WAITED AND SAID
HE COULD DO IN TEN MONTHS FOR
UNDER TEN GRAND IF THEY AGREED
TO RENAME THE SHIP.
IT'S ALMOST BELIEVABLE.
BUT SOMEHOW FIXING THE SHIP
DOESN'T QUALIFY AS
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT FREE
EDUCATION FOR ILLEGALS DOES.
SO WE CAN'T PUT OUT A FIRE BUT
WE DO TO READ UP ON ANTIRACISM
AND WHITE SUPREMACY.
WE CAN'T FIGHT FIRES BUT WE CAN
FIRE MILITARY ACADEMY MEMBERS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
APPOINTED BY TRON.
TODAY IT SEEMS THAT WOKE IS HIM
IS THE ONLY THING THAT IS FLAME
RETARDANT.
DAD AND BIDEN'S SPIDER-MAN
PAJAMAS.
BUT IT SHOWS HOW WE ARE BEATING
CHINA AT BEATING OURSELVES.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪ ♪
SPEAK OUT YOU KNOW, THE WAY
CHINA HAS BEEN ACTING LATELY,
EMBARRASSING US ON THE WORLD
STAGE, ACTING AGGRESSIVELY IN
THE SOUTH CHINA SEA AND THEN
THERE IS THE VIRUS.
I CALL IT THE CHINA VIRUS BUT I
GUESS YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO DO
THAT.
I KEEP THINKING THE
UNITED STATES IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT BUT WE KEEP
TRADING WITH THE MEN ACTING AS
IF NOTHING IS WRONG.
I GUESS IT'S BECAUSE WE ARE
NICE.
THAT'S IT.
WE ARE NICE.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: THAT HYPERSONIC
WEAPON ONLY EXPOSED THE FOLLY OF
OUR PRIORITIES.
WE NOW ARE NO LONGER COMPETING
WITH CHINA AS A SUPERPOWER.
WE ARE DISMANTLING THE
SUPERPOWER THAT WE ONCE WERE.
EVERY NEW STANDARD THAT THEIR
WEAPON SITES, WE LOWER A
STANDARD IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE ARE OUR VERY OWN ENEMY NOW
AND WE DON'T EVEN HAVE TO LET
THE WEAPON.
BECAUSE CHINA ALREADY ONE --
WHERE IT NEVER MADE IT HARD FOR
THEM.
THAT COUNTRY HAS THE ADVANTAGE
OF NOT HAVING AN ACADEMIC MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT ESTABLISHMENT
THAT WORKS OVERTIME TO SUBVERT
THEIR SECURITY.
I GUESS THAT IS PART OF AMERICA
BEING A FREE COUNTRY.
BUT WHY BE SO MALICIOUSLY STUPID
ABOUT IT JUST BECAUSE WE CAN
DESTROY YOURSELVES, WHY SHOULD
WE DESTROY OURSELVES?
SOMETHING MY PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN ASKED ME EVERY TIME HE
SEES ME SHIRTLESS.
CHINA ALSO DOES NOT PRODUCE
SOCIAL JUSTICE WHERE IS WHERE AS
WE BECOME LINES OF THESE FASCIST
CRETINS.
A NUCLEAR -- BUT ONE MO COURIER
CAN DESTROY EVERYTHING BUT LOW
BACK RADIATION.
NO WONDER THEY EMBRACE IT.
THEY GET PAID BY AMERICA WHILE
PROPPING UP AN IDEOLOGY THAT
CROPS ALL OVER AMERICA.
IT'S LIKE PAYING A HIT MAN TO
SHOOT YOUR CELL.
OUR EMBRACE BLACK LIVES MATTER
HERE WHILE EMBRACING SLAVE LABOR
THEY ARE.
AND LIKE THE WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM
IN TOKYO, AMERICA LOSES.
BECAUSE WE IGNORE THE BIGGER,
UGLIER PROBLEM BY OBSESSING OVER
PROBLEMS THAT DON'T EXIST.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THIS FLUID.
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT FLIP?
>> THIS ONE?
>> MAY BE A PEDICURE?
>> Greg: SO AS CHINA REACHES
FOR THE STARS, AND I DON'T MEAN
LeBRON JAMES OR JOHN CENA, WE
REACH FOR THE ANTIRACIST POLICY
MANUAL.
TRYING --
PERHAPS WOULD BE SHOULD BE
QUAKING ON HER BOOTS BUT THEY
ARE PROBABLY MADE IN CHINA
ANYWAY.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE HAS BEEN A MORE HOT SPOTS
THAN ALOE VERA.
LAURA LOGAN HAS NO AGENDA ON
FOX NATION, LARA LOGAN.
HE HAS EXPOSED MORE DEMOCRATS
THAN JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S FLIGHT
LOG.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
"WASHINGTON TIMES" OPINION
EDITOR, CHARLIE HURT.
WHEN HE IS HEADLINING THE VENUE,
MAXIMUM OCCUPANCY IS NOT AN
ISSUE.
COMEDIAN JOE MACHI.
AND THE ONLY TIME SHE REMAINED
SILENT AS AFTER HEARING HER
MIRANDA RIGHTS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
LARA, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
SO HAPPY -- WE JUST MET.
I WAS SCARED OF YOU.
INTIMIDATED MIGHT BE THE BEST
WORD.
DO YOU THINK THAT CHINA IS
THRILLED THAT AMERICA HAS GONE
SO WOKE?
>> YES AND WITHOUT A DOUBT.
IF YOU GO BACK TO 1999, THEY
RODE A BOOK ON ASYMMETRICAL
WARFARE AND THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING.
THEY'VE UPDATED IT SINCE.
IT COVERS EVERYTHING FROM -- ALL
ABOUT MANUFACTURING WHICH WAS
EXPOSED WHEN THE PANDEMIC HAD
TO.
WE REALIZED WITHOUT CHINA WE
HAVE NO -- NO MEDICAL EQUIPMENT
SO WHAT DID THEY DO TO CHANGE
THAT?
NOTHING.
AND WHEN CHINA GOT ALL THAT
CAPABILITY, THAT IS -- WHICH
THEY INTRODUCED AND MADE A DEAL
WITH THE MEXICAN CARTEL AND HOW
MANY AMERICANS ARE DYING EVERY
YEAR?
AND WE HEAR NOTHING ABOUT
APPEARED AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU ARE DOING DRUGS?
NOT PAYING TAXES, NOT JOINING
THE MILITARY, NOT HOLDING DOWN A
JOB.
THIS IS WHAT ASYMMETRIC WARFARE
IS ABOUT.
DISMANTLING YOUR SOCIETY FROM
WITHIN AND FOR SOME REASON
POLITICIANS TODAY -- GO TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
NOBODY CARES YOU HAVE PEOPLE
STANDING ON THE STREET PASSING
ON THEMSELVES AND EVERYWHERE.
AND UNABLE TO FUNCTION.
AND WENT TO THEY SAY?
LET'S REDUCE THE MANDATORY
MINIMUM SENTENCING FOR FENTANYL.
SO WE DON'T TALK ABOUT ANY OF
THOSE THINGS AND HOW THE DEFENSE
-- DIDN'T SEE THIS COMING.
THEY HAVE BEEN MISSING A LOT OF
STUFF.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN FOCUSING ON
THE PRONOUNS.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I WILL DARE YOU OVERLOOK THE
PRONOUNS.
I'VE TO POKE A HOLE IN YOUR
THEORY.
KAT DOES DRUGS AND SHE STILL HAS
A JOB.
RIGHT?
CHARLIE, SO GLAD YOU WORE THAT.
>> I DID IT FOR YOU.
I WAS OUT OF MY ARGYLE SOCKS BUT
THESE ARE GREAT.
>> Greg: IT SEEMS TO ME ARE
SOCIAL JUSTICE WORRIES ARE
REPLACING OUR REAL WARRIORS.
DO YOU THAT STATEMENT TO BE THE
CASE OR DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING
SMARTER TO SAY?
>> I DON'T.
AS YOU KNOW I DON'T.
IT'S AMAZING AND OBVIOUSLY THE
WORST IS THE POLITICAL SET IN
WASHINGTON WHO WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE IN CHARGE OF NOT LETTING THE
SORT OF THING HAPPEN AND LOOKING
OUT FOR AMERICA'S INTEREST AND
IT IS AMAZING WHEN A GUY LIKE
DONALD TRUMP COMES ALONG AND
EVERYBODY GETS UPSET ABOUT THE
STUFF HE SAYS IN THE WAY SAYS
AVA AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
THING THAT REALLY UPSET PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON IS THAT HIS
POLITICAL MANTRA WAS AMERICA
FIRST.
AND EVERYTHING THAT HE DID,
EVERY PLATFORM OF HIS THAT GOT
HIM ELECTED WAS DESIGNED TO
WRENCH POWER AWAY FROM
WASHINGTON LIKE DEALING WITH THE
BORDER.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET THAT
AMERICA IS NOT LOST.
JUST LOOK AT THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO STILL
BELIEVE AMERICA IS THE PLACE
THAT THEY WANT TO BE AND THEY
ARE DYING, LITERALLY, RISKING
THEIR LIVES TO COMES HERE --
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS PICO
AND THEY'RE COMING HERE BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE AMERICA IS WHAT IT
IS.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE HAVE DISCOVERED THE ENEMY AND
IT IS US.
AND ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK IT IS
THE REGULAR -- PEOPLE ARE STILL
SIGNING UP TO FIGHT.
THE TRUE WARRIORS ARE STILL
AND THUS THE REMINDER OF WHY WE
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
NONE OF US HERE HAVE A CHOICE TO
SORT OF GIVE UP AND WALK AWAY.
BECAUSE WE SO LOVE PEOPLE
SIGNING UP TO LITERALLY FIGHT
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Greg: THANK GOD FOR THAT.
JOE, WERE YOU TERRIFIED WHEN YOU
SAW THAT HYPERSONIC MISSILE?
>> I WAS TERRIFIED BUT I'VE BEEN
TERRIFIED FOR A LONG TIME ABOUT
A GREAT MANY THINGS.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
REMINDS ME OF WHEN I AM WALKING
UP THE STAIRS TO OUR OFFICE AND
THERE WILL BE A COWORKER AND I
WILL SOMETIMES START RUNNING AND
SAY LAST ONE UP AS A LOSER AND
THEY WILL BE LIKE I DIDN'T KNOW
WE WERE COMPETING.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY I CAN BEAT
KAT.
BUT WE HAVE ALL OF THESE SYMBOLS
THAT WE ARE IN A COMPETITION AND
WE ARE IGNORING IT.
WE GAVE CHINA MOST FAVORED
NATION TRADE STATUS AND THEY
START DUMPING THEIR PRODUCTS.
WE INVITE THEM IN THE WTO.
THEY START MANIPULATING THEIR
CURRENCY.
THEY TAKE OVER HONG KONG AND WE
ARE LIKE FREEDOM SUCKS.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
KAT.
IS CHINA JUST SIMPLY WAITING US
OUT?
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
WE CAN JUST FINISH THE JOB.
>> LIKE WITH A NAVAL SHIP I WAS
READING THAT ARTICLE AND IT SAID
THERE WAS A BUTTON THAT
ACTIVATED FOAM BUT NOBODY KNEW
THE LOCATION OF THE BUTTON.
AND I'M LIKE THERE WAS A BUTTON?
THINK ABOUT THAT.
HOW MANY PROBLEMS IN THE WORLD
CAN BE SOLVED WITH JUST A
BUTTON.
NOT THAT MANY.
HOW?
LIKE THAT TRAINING.
I DON'T HAVE A MILITARY
BACKGROUND --
FREEDOM IS NOT FREE.
BUT I COULD HAVE CONDUCTED THAT
TRAINING.
HERE'S THE BUTTON.
AT THAT SHIP IS ON FIRE, PUSH
IT.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES -- >> PUT A
LITTLE POST-IT NOTE.
IF SHIP ON FIRE, PUSH THE SPIRIT
ARROW.
HOW DO YOU MESSED THAT UP?
IT SEEMS HARDER TO MESS THAT UP
THEN TO NOT TO MESS THAT UP.
>> Greg: WHAT IS PUSHING THE
BUTTON SEEMS SOMEWHAT
OPPRESSIVE?
JUST THE ACTIVE PUSHING -- IT'S
AN ACT OF VIOLENCE.
SPEAK OUT ITS RACES.
>> Greg: AND MIGHT EVEN BE
RACIST.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE PUSHED
AROUND.
>> IT'S BETTER T